sitting around a campfire you can feel
its heat smell the woody smoke and hear
it crackle if you get too close it burns
your eyes and stings your nostrils you
could stare at the bright flames forever
as they twist and flicker in endless
incarnations but what exactly are you
looking at the flames are obviously not
solid nor are they liquid mingling with
the air they're more like a gas but more
visible and more fleeting and on a
scientific level fire differs from gas
because gases can exist in the same
state indefinitely while fires always
burn out eventually one misconception is
that fire is a plasma the fourth state
of matter in which atoms are stripped of
their electrons like fire and unlike the
other kinds of matter
plasmas don't exist in a stable state on
earth they only form when gas is exposed
to an electric field or super heated to
temperatures of thousands or tens of
thousands of degrees by contrast fuels
like wood and paper burn at a few
hundred degrees far below the threshold
of what's usually considered a plasma
so if fire isn't a solid liquid gas or a
plasma what does that leave it turns out
fire isn't actually matter at all
instead it's our sensory experience of a
chemical reaction called combustion in a
way fire is like the leaves changing
color in fall the smell of fruit as it
ripens or a fire flies blinking light
all of these are sensory clues that a
chemical reaction is taking place what
differs about fire is that it engages a
lot of our senses at the same time
creating the kind of vivid experience we
expect to come from a physical thing
combustion creates that sensory
experience using fuel heat and oxygen in
a campfire when the logs are heated to
their ignition temperature the walls of
their cells decompose releasing sugars
and other molecules into the air these
molecules then react with airborne
oxygen to create carbon dioxide and
water at the same time any trapped water
in the logs vaporizes expands ruptures
the wood around it and escapes with a
satisfying crackle as the fire heats up
the carbon dioxide and water vapor
created by combustion expand now that
they're less dense they rise in a
thinning column gravity causes this
expansion and rising which gives flames
their characteristic taper
without gravity molecules don't separate
by density and the flames have a totally
different shape we can see all of this
because combustion also generates the
light molecules emit light when heated
and the color of the light depends on
the temperature of the molecules the
hottest flames are white or blue the
type of molecules in a fire can also
influence flame color for instance any
unreacted carbon atoms from the logs
form little clumps of soot that rise
into the flames and emit the yellow
orange light we associate with a
campfire substances like copper calcium
chloride and potassium chloride can add
their own characteristic hues to the mix
besides colorful flames fire also
continues to generate heat as it burns
this heat sustains the flames by keeping
the fuel at or above ignition
temperature eventually though even the
hottest fires run out of fuel or oxygen
then those twisting flames give a final
hiss and disappear with a wisp of smoke
as if they were never there at all did
you know that ted-ed has an online shop
each item is inspired by a ted-ed
animation and 100% of the proceeds go
towards creating our free educational
videos and programs check it out at IDI
ted.com slash shop